now the conviction in South Africa of
eight police officers for the murder of
a mozambican taxi driver has further
tarnished the reputation of the police
in that country around a thousand people
died in South Africa every year in
police custody or as the result of
police action will earlier we spoke to
the journalist for money and kizi who's
in Durban mido macia I was stopped in
davidson while he was driving his taxi
and the police said he was causing a
traffic jam in liver will try to arrest
him and he felt it within his rights to
resist arrest and while the police
officers were resting him they
handcuffed him to the back of a pity his
van and proceeded to drag him for a
distance of about 500 meters through the
streets of Davidson this incident was
captured on software and cameras and it
went viral across the South Africa and
across the world and that incidents
highlighted a very worrying trend of
police brutality in South Africa once me
de Mesilla was dragged through the
streets of Davidson his ordeal didn't
end there MSC was actually also beaten
up in police custody and that's when he
also died and in terms of the injuries
he sustained he received lacerations on
his head when his chest on his jaw and
he also had bite marks on his on his
town their defense was the handcuff
[ __ ] was here to the back of the piece
van by accident where the judge found
that quite improbable and one of the
police officers also claimed that mido
macia attacked him and trying to disarm
by taking his farm and but they were
eight police officers on the scene and
they for judge Bird bomb found that
version of events quite improbable and
dismissed it and Robert Tom Brady threw
the book at the police officers he was
unequivocal in the telling them venture
I were guilty of furthering her we never
see her she died in a very tragic a
mutual benefit from being dragged
through the streets for about 500 meters
and also suffering extensive abuse in
police cells and he died alone
he never received medical attention
which of course would have saved his
life south africa has contains a lot of
incidents of police brutality and
convictions are quite rare and in this
incident is it was quite fortunate than
it was captured on video and therefore
it contributed to the successful
conviction of the eight police officers
sentencing is going to be held on the
twenty-second of sep tember which is
next month and in south africa the
minimum sentence for murder is 15 years
and judged by the bird bomb is a
no-nonsense SAP of judge so well it
really remains to be seen how lenient ah
oh oh how harsh he will be on him but
yeah these officers can expect to
minimum sentence of 15 years in prison
that's the journalist Romani in kizi
speaking to us from Durban a little
earlier